hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
unsurprisingly miguel de una muno is
going to refer
to the tragic sense of life at a number
of points
in his work tragic sense of life one
would
really expect him to and if you're going
to look
for a definition of what tragic sense of
life
means you're going to be a bit
disappointed because he's not going to
provide one to you as a matter of fact
given his philosophy
he would be inconsistent were he trying
to provide some
overarching fit everything into a box
characterization of that sort instead
he says that this entire work is a set
of reflections and meditations upon
the tragic sense of life so he's
approaching
this in a way that requires us to go at
it from a number
of different perspectives and bring in
a number of different thinkers as we go
through it
we find some important characterizations
that allow us to produce
you might say something like a composite
picture
of what the tragic sense of life is
supposed to be
and i think the best way to do this is
to look at
chapter one and then go directly
to the conclusion of the work and use
those as endpoints and then work our way
back inward so what does he say in in
chapter one towards the end
of the first chapter the man of flesh
and bone where he's making the point
that
philosophizing is not something purely
intellectual
and it involves the entire person when
it's authentic
genuine philosophizing we could say
this is a prime example of unamuno's
existential
position he tells us that there is
something which for lack of a better
name
we will call the tragic sense of life so
notice that
he is saying well we don't have any
better way of expressing this any more
precise way
we're going to use these terms that are
rather evocative and that people should
be able to relate to and i will say this
that tragedy had somewhat of a different
sense for the educated reader of the
early 1900s
than it necessarily does for us today
where we've cheapened the word
and used it to mean any sort of
situation where
somebody suffers something or where some
injustice has been done
tragedy is a bit deeper than that and so
we want to keep that in mind so he goes
on and he says
it carries with itself a whole
conception
of life itself and of
the universe so the tragic sense of life
is including ourselves it's including
the universe in which we find ourselves
often
not one that we've chosen in large part
but in which we
are you know fallen or thrown or however
we want to put it
using whatever terminology and of life
something that we experience something
that we
bear within us but we cannot completely
cognize we can approach through
rationality but also through willing
through
sentiment through relationships through
all of these things
and he goes on and he calls this a whole
philosophy more or less formulated
more or less conscious and that's
important there
it's it's not saying that this is always
well
worked out it's sometimes more or less
conscious that means that sometimes it
won't be
very conscious at all it'll be operating
almost by instinct
and sometimes it will be quite
reflective and conscious but it may not
be
conscious of everything there will still
be some parts that are
irrational some parts that are
subconscious some parts that
are yet to be discovered in how one
works these things out
then we can also say that
not only more or less conscious he says
more or less formulated we may not
always have the full articulation as a
matter of fact we can probably say
we won't have the entire articulation
finished philosophical systems or
anything like them
whether they're political or social
scientific or
you know other sorts of things are
probably going to
leave something important out
so this is quite important he also says
that
this is the sense may be possessed and
is possessed not only by individual
human beings
but by whole peoples and he's going to
talk about his fellow
spaniards uh the iberian you you might
say
consciousness because he's also going to
talk about portuguese
in here and he's he's also going to talk
about the basques
as well at certain points so this this
may be possessed by whole peoples and he
says
this does not so much flow from ideas
as determine them even though afterwards
it is manifest these ideas react upon it
and
confirm it so this tragic sense of life
uses ideas you could say it's in a
dialectical
relationship with ideas ideas allow it
to articulate itself
but there's something more than just the
ideas
and he also goes on and he says you know
sometimes it may originate in a chance
illness other times it's constitutional
and it's useless to speak of people who
are healthy and people who are not
healthy
apart from the fact that there's no
normal standard of health nobody has
proved that human beings are necessarily
cheerful by nature and further human
beings by the fact of being humans with
possession consciousness
is in comparison with the ass or the
crab
a diseased animal consciousness is a
disease so being conscious
and not hiding one's head in the sand or
in escapism of various sorts or
throwing oneself into some sort of you
know solve it all
movement or or you know set of ideas
is going to provoke this tragic sense of
life within us and he gives us
a listing of his own people that he
thinks
exhibit this some of whom you know
i'll admit i haven't read all of these
people myself and you probably haven't
heard
of some of them but you'll certainly
have heard of the first
several he says i recall now
these are these these are men of flesh
and bone who are typical examples of
those who possess this tragic sense of
life
he says marcus aurelius saint augustine
pascal rousseau renee
obermann thompson leopardy
vigney lanao christ amiel kental
kierkegaard and it says that these are
people who are
burdened with wisdom rather than
knowledge and so that's kind of an
interesting
list if you think about it some of these
are people that
when we talk about existentialism get
called proto-existentialists
particularly
saint augustine and uh pascal
um but all of them are are concerned
with making sense out of this this
you could call it general human
condition
in in their own way that we all have to
deal with
when we go to the conclusion which has
this very
interesting and provocative title
don quixote in the contemporary european
tragic comedy there
is a sort of philosophy within the
quixote
una muno says that one can
can sort of dig out and europe
itself your the european consciousness
has got itself away from this tragic
sense of life
and so he's got these interesting
ruminations upon
the possibility of a spanish philosophy
so he tells us this is a bit
deep in it he's he's talking about
somebody who really nobody reads anymore
but was a very
popular german author uh of the
you know doing a lot of things
particularly the history of philosophy
wendell bond and he tells us that that
vindal bond
thinks that you know uh philosophy in
the systematic sense is the critical
knowledge of values of universal
validity
and unimogo goes on and says what values
are there more universal validity than
that of the human will
seeking before all the personal
individual and concrete immortality of
the soul or in other words the human
finality
of the universe what values are there
more universal validity
than the rational mathematical value and
the volitional or teleological value
of the universe in conflict with each
other and here we're getting to
something
that is really key to this tragic sense
of life
we have as human beings these various
modes of using our
consciousness to understand things to
understand
vital domains of life and rationality
and the sciences are one way in which we
do that but the person who confines
himself to just those
is in a certain sense not even a tragic
being but rather a comic being
a truncated being somebody who is not
grasping
at least the available totality of
existence i won't say the entire
totality of existence but there is so
much more
than just what can be made rational and
so he goes on and he says um
here we go um
we will be told yet again there's never
been any spanish philosophy in the
technical sense of the word
i will answer by asking what is this
sense what does
philosophy mean
and vindle bond and people like him say
that it's really just philosophy
as science and he goes and he says
doesn't philosophy have any other office
to perform
may not its office be to reflect upon
the tragic sense of life itself
such as we've been studying it in this
book to formulate this conflict between
reason and faith between science and
religion
and deliberately here's the key right
here to perpetuate
this conflict now that is a really
good formulation of what philosophy
could be doing
and what existentialist philosophy in
fact in some cases does
it realizes that we have these different
domains and they don't all have to
actually end up
on the same page we don't have to turn
everything into science
we don't have to turn everything into
some brand of philosophy
we don't have to accept these sorts of
claims we also don't have to allow
religion to dominate everything we can
realize the conflict between these
and philosophy doesn't have to say ah
well i'm either going to be the handmaid
of theology or the handmaid of the
sciences
that's that's not the only option
available for us
philosophy can look at this tragic
conflict that we have within ourselves
and instead of simply trying to resolve
this conflict
it can perpetuate it as unamuno says
that is not going to be
something that philosophers like
vindlebond or really many people
in philosophy departments are going to
be particularly
happy to do although you know it's kind
of funny because it would provide you at
least
some job security would it not right
so if you're thinking in purely economic
motives which are not tragic motives
that might have some some play he goes
on a little bit later in the chapter
and he says that um
philosophy is the science
of the tragedy of life a reflection on
the tragic
sense of it an essay in this philosophy
with
its inevitable internal contradictions
and antinomies is what i have attempted
in these essays again
una muno is not trying to harmonize
everything he's not trying to explain
contradictions away
he wants these contradictions to come to
the fore and to provoke their
emotional or affective responses on our
part
so that we're really aware of the
problems that are that are posed
before us and we can cultivate this
in terms of this overarching tragic
sense of life so i think
chapter one in the conclusion gave you
some good ideas about what's going on
here
there are a couple places where he talks
about the
basis or the source of the
tragic sense of life but it might be
good to focus
on something that's happening in the
middle of the book in chapter six
where he talks about this religious
despair
and he talks about suffering
and dealing with all of these sorts of
matters so
he tells us that
here we go i have brought the reader
who's had the patience to follow me
halfway through the book endeavoring
always to do equal justice to the claims
of reason and feeling i don't want to
keep silence on matters about which
others are silence
i have sought to strip naked not only my
own soul but the human soul
be its nature what it is its destiny to
disappear or not to disappear
and we have arrived at the bottom of the
abyss at the irreconcilable
conflict between reason and vital
feeling and he goes on and he says that
he who looks for reasons strictly
so-called scientific arguments
technically logical reflections may
refuse to follow me further anybody's
free to read whatever they want anybody
can follow along
you there's there's no like absolute
internal necessity
to go along with una muno in this
discussion of the tragic sense of life
but he says that i hope to gather
everything together and to show that
this religious despair
which i have been talking about which is
nothing other
than the tragic sense of life itself is
though more or less hidden the very
foundation of the consciousness
of civilized individuals and peoples
today so he's saying there's something
going on
we can hide ourselves from it and we can
find a million ways to distract
ourselves
but if we're sufficiently attentive and
sufficiently bold
to follow out what's really going on
we will discover this tragic sense of
life
at the bottom and the tragic sense of
life is a sense
for this interminable conflict between
these
you might say polarities of the human
being
he goes on and he says of those
individuals and those peoples who do not
suffer from stupidity of intellect or
stupidity of feeling
notice that isn't that an interesting
parallel there
stupidity of intellect an inability to
use your intellect
well to follow things through to their
very ends
but we can also have a stupidity of
feeling he's not just talking about
emotional intelligence by the way here
he is talking about something that goes
deeper than that recent psychological
movement
which is useful itself in its own right
and
often best when it's drawing upon
classic philosophy as it does a little
bit of a digression
there so he he says that this
tragic sense is the spring
of heroic achievements
now isn't that an interesting way to
describe it
it's the spring of heroic achievements
why
because in order to do anything
genuinely
heroic you don't have the whole thing
laid out for you in advance with a nice
checklist
and everything in its place and a set of
procedures that you just follow
from point to point to point you
actually have to
stake your own life you actually have to
commit yourself you actually have to
take
choices that you'll take responsibility
for and say yes i could be wrong about
this but i am going to go
slay the hydra or you know tackle
whatever else has to be tackled it's
good to remember that one of
hercules jobs if we're talking about
heroic was cleaning out a terrible
uh you know area full of manure
now of course he found a way to do that
was kind of crazy that
isn't available for all of us but the
this tragic sense of life leads us to be
able to take on
things that are in some degree
beyond what we think we're capable of
it doesn't have to be heroism in the
sense of saving entire peoples of
nations it could be
heroism in terms of loving somebody
who is largely unlovable and
sticking with that and not doing so just
out of a sense of resignation
right but doing so out of a
vast adventure that you're on it could
be all sorts of things
don quixote who he talks about in the
end
may be an emblem of this as well
now we should talk about this this basis
or
source as well in chapter
2 early on in the work he is going to
tell us
that the basis of the tragic sense of
life lies in the realization
of a certain conflict he says
living is one thing knowing is another
as we shall see perhaps there is such an
opposition between the two we may say
that everything vital is anti-rational
not merely irrational
and that everything rational is
anti-vital and this
is the basis of the tragic sense of
life this awareness of the conflict the
things that cannot be
completely assimilated to each other but
which which attempt to
and then in chapter 9 he talks about
this eternal
anguish and he's it's in the the context
of a discussion
of suffering which is
quite important
here we go he he tells us that
this is in the chapter on faith hope and
charity
he says suffering is the substance of
life and the root of personality
it is only suffering that makes us
persons and suffering is universal
suffering is that which unites all us
living beings together
that which we call will what is it but
suffering and then he says and suffering
has degrees
according to the depth of its
penetration from the suffering that
floats on the sea of appearances
to the eternal anguish the source
of the tragic sense of life which seeks
a habitation in the depths of the
eternal
and there awakens consolation from the
physical suffering that contorts our
bodies to
religious anguish so then he says
anguish is something far deeper
more intimate and more spiritual than
just
suffering and what is he talking about
there well
our response to this conflict between
we could say reason and life or between
uh the objects of religion and the
objects of science or the activities
this conflict within us is is not just
purely individual it's not about you
know taking the
the person who's suffering and then
adjusting them to society
the way that ego psychology wanted to do
in early in the
last century no it's about realizing
that this
is the human condition and we can hide
this from ourselves
or we can actually do justice to it
within ourselves and that is the source
of this thing that he calls the
tragic sense of life this entire book
is devoted to providing insights
into this tragic sense of life and
leading us to be able to
more clearly cognize it as i mentioned
before he doesn't provide definitions
but i think that these
characterizations might be quite helpful
as you're approaching bunamuno's great
work
you